[Music]
which of these three people is doing
something risky is it the one who takes
their cholesterol medication with
grapefruit juice the one who takes
acetaminophen pain relievers for a sore
ankle before going out for drinks or the
one who's on a blood thinning medication
and takes an aspirin for a headache
actually all of them honor each has
inadvertently created a drug interaction
that could in extreme cases lead to
kidney failure liver damage or internal
bleeding drug interactions happen when a
combination of a drug with another
substance causes different effects than
either would individually foods herbal
supplements legal drugs and illicit
substances can all cause drug
interactions most drug interactions fall
into two categories some take place when
two substances effects influence each
other directly in other cases one
substance affects how the body processes
another like how it is absorbed
metabolized or transported around the
body blood thinners and aspirin for
example have similar effects that become
dangerous when combined both prevent
blood clots from forming blood thinners
by preventing the formation of the
clotting factors that hold clots
together and aspirin by preventing blood
cells from clumping into groups that
become clots individually these effects
are usually safe but taken together they
can prevent blood clotting to a
dangerous extent possibly causing
internal bleeding while blood thinners
and aspirin are generally harmless when
taken individually interactions where
one substance exacerbates the effects of
another can also take place between
drugs that are independently harmful
cocaine and heroin are each dangerous
and those dangers compound when the two
drugs are combined even though their
behavioural effects may feel like they
cancel each other out caffeine is a
stimulant and many of its effects like
increased heart rate cause the body to
need more
but heroin a depressant slows breathing
reducing the body's and oxygen supply it
just when it needs more this combination
strains the organs and can cause
respiratory failure and death the
interaction between grapefruit juice and
certain medications in a class of
cholesterol-lowering drugs called
statins has to do with drug metabolism
the liver produces enzymes molecules
that facilitate the breakdown of
substances that enter their body enzymes
can both activate drugs by breaking them
down into their therapeutic ingredients
from more complex molecules and
deactivate them by breaking harmful
compounds down into harmless metabolites
there are many many different enzymes
each of which has a binding site that
fits a specific molecule grapefruit
binds to the same enzyme as statins
making less of that enzyme available to
break down statins so combining the two
means that a greater concentration of
the drug stays in the bloodstream for a
longer period of time potentially
causing kidney failure alcohol can also
alter the function of the enzyme that
breaks down acetaminophen the active
ingredient in pain relievers like
tylenol and paracetamol when someone
takes acetaminophen some of it is
converted into a toxic substance at the
recommended dose there isn't usually
enough of this toxic by-product to cause
harm but heavy drinking can alter enzyme
activities so more of that by-product is
produced potentially causing liver
damage even with what's usually a safe
dose of acetaminophen meanwhile the
herbal remedies st. John's wort
increases the livers production of a
particular enzyme
means the drugs this enzyme is
responsible for breaking down get
metabolized faster sometimes too fast
before they can have their therapeutic
effects in spite of the dizzying number
of possible interactions most of the
dangerous interactions with commonly
used drugs are well-known and new
developments in science are helping us
keep better track of drug interactions
than ever some researchers are
developing AI programs that can predict
the side-effects of drug interactions
before they occur using information
about the landscape of protein
interactions within your body for the
new drugs that are being developed all
the time supercomputers are being used
to find potential interactions while
those drugs are still in development
when you take medicine how does it know
where it needs to go find out by
following the path of medicine as it
travels through the body in this video
[Music]